>>> I'M SO GLAD TO HAVE MY NEXT
GUEST HERE BECAUSE HE'LL GIVE US
THE INFORMATION WE NEED.
CNN IS LEARNING PRESIDENT BIDEN
IS WEIGHING WHETHER TO EXTEND
THE AUGUST 31st DEADLINE FROM
REMOVING ALL U.S. TROOPS FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
THEY BRIEFED LAWMAKERS ON THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE ON THE
CRISIS UNFOLDING AND THE AS THE
HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE IS
INVESTIGATING PLANS TO ASK
COMPANIES TO PRESERVE THE PHONE
RECORDS OF MULTIPLE PEOPLE
INCLUDING SOME MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
LET'S GET TO IT WITH DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN ADAM SCHIFF.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US.
GOOD EVENING.
A LOT TO GET TO ON AFGHANISTAN.
I WANT TO START WITH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING JANUARY
6th.
YOU'RE ON THAT COMMITTEE.
BENNY THOMPSON, THE COMMITTEE'S
CHAIR CONFIRMING TO CNN HE WANTS
TELL LACOMBE COMPANIES TO
PRESERVE PHONE RECORDS TO
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND KEVIN
McCARTHY, JIM JORDAN SPOKE WITH
TRUMP ON JANUARY 6th.
WHOSE RECORDS DO YOU WANT TO
SEE?
>> WELL, I'M GOING TO LEAVE IT
AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE TO THE
CHAIRMAN TO MAKE THOSE
DISCLOSURES PUBLIC OR IN A
FORMAL ANNOUNCEMENT.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS, WE INTEND
TO BE THOROUGH.
WE WANT TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
TOOK PLACE BEFORE JANUARY 6th
THAT LED TO THAT TRAGIC DAY AND
THE VIOLENCE OF THAT DAY.
ANYONE INVOLVED AND ANYONE WHO
HAD KNOWLEDGE WHO WOULD BE
ASSEMBLING ON THAT MALL OR THE
VIOLENCE TO COME, ANYONE THAT
FUNDED IT, WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE
WAS DOING, PEOPLE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION, WHAT THEY WERE
AWARE OF AND WHEN, WHY WE
WEREN'T REINFORCED IN THE
CAPITOL, WHY IT TOOK SO MANY
HOURS TO SEND THE NATIONAL
GUARD.
SO WE WANT ANSWERS TO ALL THESE
QUESTIONS AND WE'RE NOT AFRAID
TO ASK THEM OF ANYONE INCLUDING
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, FORMER
MEMBERS OF THE ADMINISTRATION,
CURRENT PEOPLE THAT ARE SERVING
WITHIN ADMINISTRATION, ANYONE
WHO HAS RELEVANT INFORMATION.
>> YEAH.
LISTEN, YOUR ANSWER MAY BE
SIMILAR BUT I HAVE TO ASK IT
ANYWAYS, LETTERS ARE GOING OUT,
GOING TO BE SENT TO SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES.
ARE YOU ABLE TO SAY WHICH ONES
AND HOW EXPANSIVE YOU SEE THIS
INVESTIGATION COMING?
>> I CAN'T.
I CAN SAY THIS FOLLOWS A VERY
TRADITIONAL INVESTIGATIVE PATH
WHERE YOU WANT TO GET THE
DOCUMENTS FIRST BEFORE YOU BRING
IN WITNESSES SO YOU KNOW THE
RIGHT QUESTIONS TO ASK AND WE
ARE WORKING IN A VERY BIPARTISAN
INDEED NON-PARTISAN WAY AND
BROUGHT ON VERY CAPABLE INVEST
G
-- INVESTIGATIVE STAFF.
WE'RE GETTING WELL SITUATED TO
GET THIS IMPORTANT WORK DONE AND
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
INVESTIGATIONS CONGRESS HAS EVER
UNDER TAKEN.
>> APPRECIATE YOU TALKING ABOUT
THAT.
LET'S TURN TO AFGHANISTAN, SHALL
WE?
WHEN YOU TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHAT
YOU HEARD IN THE INTEL BRIEFING
WITH IMAGES COMING OUT OF KABUL,
VOLATILE SITUATION ON THE
GROUND.
THE AMERICAN CITIZENS AND AFGHAN
ALLIES WHO ARE THERE AND STILL
NEED TO BE EVACUATED, GIVE ME
YOUR REAL ASSESSMENT OF THIS
SITUATION, CONGRESSMAN?
>> YOU PRETTY DIRE.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS THAT NEED TO BE
EVACUATED.
AMERICANS FIRST AND FOREMOST AND
U.S. RESIDENTS BUT PEOPLE THAT
HAVE A MORAL AND ETHICAL
OBLIGATION TO.
THOSE WHO FOUGHT BESIDE US AND
INTELLIGENCE TO SAVE AMERICAN
LIVES AND AS WELL AS CIVIL
SOCIETY FIGURES THAT WE WERE
WORKING WITH TO TRY TO ESTABLISH
A GOVERNMENT THAT WOULD PROTECT
CITIZENS INCLUDING THE RIGHTS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS AND SO THAT'S A
BIG GROUP OF PEOPLE AND I'M
ENCOURAGED THAT WE HAVE REALLY
RAMPED EFFORTS UP IN THE LAST 24
TO 48 HOURS WITH 11,000 PEOPLE
EVACUATED IN A SINGLE DAY.
THAT'S PRETTY -- THAT'S PRETTY
EXTRAORDINARY NUMBER BUT THERE
ARE SO MANY MORE YET TO EVACUATE
THAT WE'VE GOT A LOT OF HARD
WORK AHEAD OF US UNDER DANGEROUS
CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> LISTEN, YOU'RE THERE.
YOU KNOW.
YOU GOT THE INTEL BRIEFINGS.
YOU KNOW MORE THAN WE DO AND
CERTAINLY SOME THINGS YOU CAN'T
REVEAL.
LET'S PUT UP THOSE IMAGES AT THE
KABUL AIRPORT.
YOU'VE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
THREAT AT THAT AIRPORT.
WE'VE SEEN PLENTY OF VIDEOS
SHOWING CROWDS OF PEOPLE
DESPERATE TO GET IN.
DO YOU THINK THE U.S. NEEDS TO
DO MORE TO BEEF UP SECURITY OR
DO YOU THINK THAT RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE DOING WHAT'S NEEDED TO
BE DONE?
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT IT?
>> WELL, I GUESS I WOULD SAY
THERE CAN NEVER BE ENOUGH
SECURITY AT THAT AIRPORT.
IT'S SUCH A CHAOTIC SITUATION
AND WHEN YOU MASS THAT NUMBER OF
PEOPLE.
PEOPLE CAN GET HURT JUST BEING
IN A CROWD THAT SIZE BUT MAKES A
VERY ATTRACTIVE TARGET FOR OUR
ENEMIES, FOR ISIS FOR EXAMPLE
LIKE NOTHING BETTER THAN TO
ATTACK, SET OFF A SUICIDE BOMB
IN THAT CROWD OR TAKE OUT ONE OF
THOSE AIRCRAFT WITH A MAN PAD.
THAT COUWOULD BE OBVIOUSLY
CATASTROPHIC AND THEY WOULD LOVE
TO SEE THAT KA AT TCATASTROPHE.
IT'S A DIFFICULT DANGEROUS
SITUATION.
WE HAVE THE BEST TRAINED
MILITARY IN THE WORLD BUT THIS
IS A FIRST CLASS, FIRST ORDER
SAFETY LOGISTICS NIGHTMARE AND
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO USE ALL
THE SKILLS WE HAVE.
>> YEAH, AS YOU SAY THE WORDS
GOD FORBID LET'S HOPE THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN WHAT YOU SAID BUT
YES, A VERY REAL POSSIBILITY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
SO YOU ALSO SAY -- YOU SAY WE
SHOULD HAVE A MILITARY PRESENCE
IN AFGHANISTAN AS LONG AS IT
TAKES TO GET TO U.S. CITIZENS
AND ALLIES AND AFGHAN ALLIES BUT
THE TALIBAN SAY ANY DELAY TO
THIS AUGUST 31st DEADLINE, THEY
SAY IT A RED LINE.
ARE YOU WORRIED AN EXTENSION
COULD PUT EVEN MORE LIVES IN
JEOPARDY HERE?
>> WELL, I'M CERTAINLY CONCERNED
ABOUT ANY EFFORT BY THE TALIBAN
TO GO AFTER PEOPLE AFTER THE END
OF THE MONTH.
BUT I'M -- LOOK, I'M VERY
MINDFUL OF THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE STILL MANY TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE WE NEED TO GET OUT AND
GETTING PEOPLE TO THAT AIRPORT
IS VERY DIFFICULT AND THE END OF
THE MONTH WILL BE ON US BEFORE
WE KNOW IT AND I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO MAINTAIN OUR MILITARY
PRESENCE LONG ENOUGH TO GET
EVERYONE OUT, CERTAINLY OUR OWN
PEOPLE OUT BUT ALSO THOSE WE
HAVE THAT MORAL OBLIGATION TO
HELP EVACUATE.
SO LOOK, I SUPPORT THE
WITHDRAWAL OF OUR U.S. FORCES
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT MADE THE
RIGHT DECISION.
WE COULD BE THERE ANOTHER FIVE,
TEN, 15 YEARS AND STILL BE IN
THE SAME SITUATION IN TERMS OF
THE TALIBAN TAKEOVER.
BUT WE SHOULDN'T LEAVE UNTIL WE
GET ALL OF OUR PEOPLE OUT AND
THOSE THAT WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO HELP GET TO SAFETY.
>> YEAH.
CNN IS REPORTING THAT THE U.S.
IS SCRAMBLING TO FILL AN
INTELLIGENCE VACUUM IN THE
AFTERMATH OF AFGHANISTAN'S
COLLAPSE.
ARE YOU WORRIED THAT ALL OF THIS
INSTABILITY COULD EMBOLDEN
EXTREMIST GROUPS AGAIN TO CARRY
OUT AN ATTACK YOU MENTIONED AT
THE AIRPORT BUT CARRY OUT ON
ATTACK AT HOME OR ABROAD,
CONGRESSMAN?
>> WELL, LOOK, WHEN YOU DRAW
DOWN YOUR MILITARY FOOTPRINT
SOMEWHERE, YOU LOSE EYES ON SOME
OF THE DANGERS THAT EXIST, BUT I
THINK WE HAVE TO ACREKNOWLEDGE E
DANGER IN THE COUNTRY IS GREATER
OUTSIDE OF AFGHANISTAN IN TERMS
OF TERRORIST ATTACK THAT MAY BE
ORGANIZED AGAINST THE HOMELAND
SO THERE ARE OTHER PARTS OF THE
WORLD WHERE AL QAEDA HAS A
BIGGER PRESENCE AND ISIS HAS A
BIGGER PRESENCE BUT OVER TIME,
THAT COULD CHANGE IN
AFGHANISTAN.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO TRY TO
KEEP A CLOSE WATCH TO MAKE SURE
AL QAEDA DOESN'T RECONSTITUTE
ITSELF THERE AND TAKE ACTION
AGAINST ISIS K AND MAKE SURE
THAT IT DOESN'T POSE A GROWING
THREAT TO US.
THAT'S MORE DIFFICULT TO DO WHEN
YOU DON'T HAVE THOSE TROOPS
STILL ON THE GROUND BUT OF
COURSE, WHEN WE DID HAVE THE
TROOPS ON THE GROUND, THEY WERE
TARGETS AND WE WERE RISKING
AMERICAN LIVES IN THAT FASHION,
TOO.
SO NOT A BRIGHT LINE HERE BUT I
THINK THE DRAW DOWN IS THE RIGHT
DECISION, AND WE'RE JUST GOING
TO HAVE TO REALLY STRENGTHEN OUR
INTELLIGENCE GATHERING
CAPABILITY FROM OTHER PLACES.
>> LOOK, WE APPRECIATE HAVING
OUR LEADERS ON TO SPEAK TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ESPECIALLY
SOMEONE LIKE YOU AND THE
COMMITTE